chérie tu pourra m'aider avec le contrat
de la succursale à ce que je comprends
rien non je m'arrête et je veux pas là
les gones toujours non non non léo lipad
maman vieux os en sac de cours moi c'est
les enfants tout le temps les enfants ça
va facturer à déposer à l'école les
enfants et à toutes les journées pour
tout péter ça va c'est sérieux la jeune
reine important que prendra place
vraiment tout est noté tous les plats
cuisinés pour ce soir là sont déjà au
frigo oh oui
ensuite sur retourne à l'école et tu
déposes les enfants reçoivent auch aux
os et aux droits ou mais où est la
droite drogue
ensuite tu me retourne chercher maxime
qui l'attendra chez son copain les ondes
ça va passer de la sécu on a ensuite eu
fini avec joseph
et chris et moi ni combien de matches
que moi ça va travailler là maintenant
je souhaite y deviendra papa c'est votre
faute qui décide ça c'est lundi donc tu
as de la chance parce que c'est un jour
calme maintenant
le mardi
comment gérer première règle fille à ton
papa qu'est ce que tu as other
exportable rien aucun résultat pour
comment gérer premier règle fille